what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are covering the life of
Captain Marvel and this is actually this
is written by Margaret Stohl and this is
essentially a reworking of really the
origin of Carol Danvers it's it's
somewhat of a retcon but it doesn't wipe
everything away right like it is kind of
we works a little bit and kind of ties
it into the nature of her character and
so what does initially does is it picks
up with what's basically hats well sound
out in Maine which is kind of like the
vacation spot for Carol Danvers and her
and her two brothers and it's kind of
interesting with this whole little thing
going on because what this does is it
kind of taught it initially starts out
kind of innocuous and this is like hey
like we used to hang out here we used to
have fun you know my brother used to get
in like fights and things like that you
know we were basically like hoodlums
more or less but then as it goes on what
we end up learning here is that joe
danvers the father of carol was actually
abusive now this is one of the changes
that Margaret Stohl makes and the reason
why is if you got like a new look at the
original Miss Marvel back in 1970 where
7776 was a nation number 13 in 1978
while joe danvers was a dick and he was
really he really seemed very sexist
there was really no indication that he
was abusive towards his wife and his and
his kids and his sons if anything he was
just a jerk and that was really about it
so kind of changing a little bit is is
somewhat interesting because what it
does is it's really kind of a change for
the sake of the story as opposed to a
change for the sake of Carroll herself
but it's interesting here because
sitting down and talking to Tony Stark
the two of them come to a kind of
understanding in terms of the fact that
they both have pretty checkered past
when it comes to their parents and so
again this happens like quick fast and
in a hurry there's not a lot going here
instead what ends up happening if she
basically travels back to Boston where
she was originally raised and start you
know of course meets with like Lewis you
know a guy that she was I guess really
seemed to have an interest in her when
he was younger and and so on and trying
to go back and like visit her family now
this is kind of an interesting thing
because over the years carol danvers
backstory in terms of her family has
been intact so Margaret Stohl is not
really changing a whole lot here but
with this whole scenario unfolding what
we end up learning is that a lot of the
history that was there remains intact in
the sense that like Chism really visit
her family all that often they never
really see her there really seems to be
some animosity you know from her younger
brother towards herself you know from
Joe Jr towards you know Carol proper but
the fact remains that there's a lot of
unspoken problems here in the sense that
like the actions of Joe and being very
very abusive are kind of swept under the
rug it is one of these things with the
family just
never really seem to deal with it and
because they never really seem to deal
with that everybody's struggling in a
variety of different ways Joe juniors
turned to alcohol he's not a full-blown
alcoholic but he has turned to alcohol
mary is really just kind of closed off
in a lot of different ways is one of
these crazy scenarios but in the middle
of all this when they go to the tomb
when they go to the gravesite of joe
danvers and of course carol danvers
freaks out ends up punching the
gravestone basically destroying it when
her brother takes off he is up getting
into an into a car wreck only for him to
basically succumb to brain damage now
this is interesting because what it does
is it shows the human side of Carol and
this is not something that you see very
often when it comes to carol danvers
when it comes to her actions when it
comes to her role as a superhero in
Marvel Comics nine times out of ten
she's just fighting some foe somewhere
in reality I would say that Carol
Danvers was never really a relevant
character in Marvel Comics until she
became a leader of the Mighty Avengers
and we got Kelly sudoc onyx run when she
took over the mantle of Captain Marvel
but to that point she really was just a
background character but the idea behind
this is going through and looking you
know going through her personal
belongings and so on and so forth
refusing to make contact with the
Avengers focusing instead on helping Joe
junior gain some measure of a return to
his normal self or at least hoping that
he does she ends up coming out coming
across the belongings of her father and
discovering like all these old letters
were written to a woman only for Carol
to realize her father was actually
having an affair and so in this moment
she grabs his kind of technological
device that was inside this this
container and then just kind of like
cracks it open and then in her
frustration to sort of leaves it there
storms out as they're going to help her
mom out with Joe and then of course the
device sort of takes off into the into
space and is of contacting this old
orbital station that belonged to the
Kree Empire now a little bit of history
here a little bit of this this is a very
very important detail when it came to
the Kree race the origins of the of the
Kree we already have a video on that so
we only really need to go through like
the whole origin of the creek but when
it comes to the planet Earth and this is
actually explaining this to Mariah this
is a really good way to think of an
Earth's location in relation to the Kree
and the Skrulls going to war against one
another is one of these things where
it's basically in a very strategic spot
it's like the Battle of Midway in World
War two right like if the Japanese won
the US would have lost the war like that
would that would have been the end of it
and so that's how earth is placed
because of this where the scrolls have
tried to conquer earth and the cria try
to conquer earth there are these little
artifacts these little devices and so on
that either
observe earth or the very least can be
activated later on that serve the
purpose of allowing one of the races to
conquer earth somewhere alone one and in
this instance it was basically
of embryo of sorts in the sense that
once it was activated it would germinate
and then like grow rapidly into a
full-blown being which in turn could
serve a particular task and so from here
what you end up doing is picking up
again with Carol kinda reflecting on her
own past reflecting on some of the
events that unfolded only for this being
to essentially crash land on earth of
course it being a creek and then
essentially go on this kind of warpath
trying to locate quote-unquote the
traitor of course the traitor for for
all intents and purposes really seems to
be Carol Danvers and in fact Margaret
Stohl plays with that and the reason why
is because the root of of Carol Danvers
really lies in treachery in the sense
that you had Marvel the original Captain
Marvel who was a Kree soldier um he was
sent to earth to see whether or not
earth care or at least to prepare for
being conquered by the Kree he turned
coded he defected joined the Avengers
and then was labeled a traitor by the
Kree Empire and that led to the arrival
of general yon [ __ ] and like the Kree
race trying to recapture Marvell the
kree-skrull war all that different kinds
of stuff and so with those things
happening kill Danvers gained her powers
by way of the psyche magnetron Wright
who was basically like a wishing machine
if you were thrown into it it would make
your wishes come true
she watched Captain Marvel wishes she
could be just like him and thus she got
half his physiology she became part Cree
and then went forward with all of her
powers and so like her her entire basis
is rooted in the treachery of the
original Marvel of the original Captain
Marvel in Marvel Comics so grabbing the
letters taking him to her mom it really
seems to kind of get swept under the rug
and this is like hey I don't want to
have anything to do with this I don't
want to see this you know I don't want
to know about your father having an
affair or anything along those lines
it's the idea like your father wanted
more it's very much her mother playing
the victim role in this sense of like
when Carol Danvers looks at her mom she
sees her mom is a victim of domestic
abuse and instead of seeing her mom as
someone who would just say like I was a
victim there I never should have been in
this situation in the first place
instead she really seems to to still
play the role of a person who's still
being victimized by her husband she's
still sides with him she still says well
there were times when I deserved it she
still says things like well you know
your father was looking for something
more so I can't really blame him seeing
him as being in the right which drives
Carol Danvers up the wall absolutely
drives her bonkers and makes sure when I
lose her mind and so it's kind of crazy
because again with this create a
cyclists ending out these kind of homing
beacons and then finally located where
does the traders located at once she
actually gets there all hell breaks
loose in the second is this small little
quiet town is literally explosions like
this whole place is almost razed to the
ground and it's kind of nuts when it
when it does take place because
initially what we end up fine
is that when this Liz alien shows up
starts rage in this place starts tearing
everything up in turn like Carol Danvers
mom basically says look like it's not
looking for you the person is looking
for is me and that's when the mother of
Carol Danvers reveals herself to be a
Kree now this is kind of a big deal this
is wholly new again Carol Danvers was
always human
she worked in Cape Canaveral she was an
Air Force pilot she witnessed the one of
the first exploits of Marvel which is
how she became enamored if not
romantically attracted to him and that
in turn eventually led her to being
caught in the conflict between jaan
raghav and Marvel in this instance is
basically saying like she has half free
physiology and she always did she just
never knew now why this retcons even
happening in the first place I don't
really know I assume that Marvel is just
kind of copying what the movies gonna do
and then in turn throwing it into the
comic book since at this point at this
point in time in Marvel Comics it's
really Marvel copying the movies as
opposed to the movies copying Marvel but
nonetheless EO is it's kind of
interesting with us this whole scenario
or so jumping back to the planet of
Halle one of the things we end up
finding out here is that the mother of
carol mary was basically trained as a
warrior on the planet Halle itself now
this is intriguing because the mother of
Carol is not that old she's only a few
decades old and one of the things that
we don't see here is the supreme
intelligence the supreme intelligence is
basically an organism that taps into and
really kind of houses the brains of like
the smartest creosote each time a genius
Kree dies its brain gets plugged into
the supreme intelligence in that way the
intelligence can literally use like
mathematical formulas and calculations
to determine what the best course of
action should be the supreme
intelligence been around for a long long
time the woman who's basically speaking
directly to Mary here who's telling her
you're gonna go to earth and you're
gonna operate there as an agent
underground you're essentially gonna
have like a cloaking device it'll hide
what you really look like it'll make you
look human
she's an empress meaning she's the
leader of the creed which really kind of
begs the question where's the supreme
intelligence so again a bit of a
continuity error here but we can kind of
roll away that we can kind of go with it
and just say what have you and just sort
of let things slide because the reason
why is that in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we probably will not see the
Supreme intelligence instead we'll see
an emperor or an empress so again it's
the comics copying the movies and so
with this going forward what we end up
having of course is the mother of carol
danvers facing off against the secrete
soldier and doing the best she can but
again this Kree soldier is designed for
the purpose of capturing traitors and
what this means is that the Kree soldier
has to be capable of taking down almost
any other Kree and encounters and so
what this means is that
it possesses a myriad of different
abilities super strength speed flight so
on and so forth and so again it's more
than a formidable fight for her Carol
Danvers mom but again at this point
Carol starts [ __ ] be given the bean
spilled in a variety of different ways
in the sense that her mom sits her down
and says look my name is is actually
Mariela that's my actual Kree given name
i right here on earth i fell in love
with your father i didn't want to betray
humanity like i wanted to stay here
again Margaret Stohl is borrowing
heavily from Marvel it's one of these
things where she always wanted to reveal
the truth of what she was to her husband
and then ultimately did but of course he
stayed by her side the two of them got
married but that's the reason why when
the husband became so abusive Mary
wasn't able to just readily leave but
it's kind of ironic because Mary could
have killed her husband it's it's kind
of crazy seeing these events unfold and
seeing these events happen the way they
did is because not everything was what
it appeared to be not only that Harold's
mother wanted to tell Carole over and
over again what she was capable of what
she could do but ultimately she didn't
ultimately was kinda like look we were
trying to give you the most human life
you could possibly have we literally
destroyed the device that was being used
to monitor me they would assume that I
was killed and that would be the end of
that and we wouldn't have to worry about
them anymore but again all of it comes
to a head when it didn't play out
exactly the way that Mary thought it
would that when the device was turned
back on again by Carol that what it did
is a set a homing beacon and said hey
look I'm still alive and because so much
time had passed it was believed that she
had betrayed her mission which she did
and was essentially a traitor and that's
what gets us to where we are right now
and so again it's interesting to see it
take place when this happens when this
this message is essentially sent out
that the the empress basically says hey
look you know this recorded device the
embers of course doesn't really seem to
be there anymore but it's you're a
traitor you know you have been found
guilty you're going to be executed here
so again Carol stands in and fights
against this being against you I guess
on behalf of her mom of course for her
mom to also join in as well between the
two of them is a very formidable fight
but of course they overcome this villain
quick fast and in a hurry because the
story's not really about the villain but
it's kind of intriguing here because one
of the things that that her mom really
hits out with Carol is she basically
says look the powers that you got did
not come from the psych magnatron that's
not how that worked
you always had these powers all this did
was unlocked and now this also kind of
begs the question of the binary powers
because it also says your binary powers
were unlocked and we can take this one
of two ways either we can integrate it
in or we can just say that Margaret
Stohl
probably made a mistake here but really
like integrating it in what we could say
is that all this like magnetron did was
activate the
powers of Carol Danvers which in and of
itself kind of defies the nature of the
psyche magnetron again we can kind of
make it work we can say well if the
psych magnetron was basically a wishing
machine and it active and Danielle Carol
Danvers said I wish that I could be just
like here like Captain Marvel well then
in turn it activated her powers instead
of as opposed to giving her powers and
then in turn if we fast forward to Chris
Claremont x-men and we have the brood
which basically like gives Carol Danvers
the white dwarf powers whatever it is it
turns her into binary all the brood did
was activate those powers as opposed to
give her new set a new set of powers so
again you can find ways to kind of fit
it in and it just sort of requires that
you just don't read the original content
but you don't go back and read those
original stories otherwise it won't fit
in it's because of the way that it's
written the way that it's done it's it's
literally the brooder like we're giving
you these powers you know and it's like
this like magnetron is you are now
blended halfway with with Marvel you now
have half Kree physiology like it's
literally like there's no way around
this like this is definitively what's
going on it's not ambiguous in any form
or fashion and so again it's somewhat
intriguing here but you can kind of make
it work you can sort of cook the books
fudge the numbers we're just kind of
what Marvel's relying on is that you're
not gonna go back and read the old
stories which in reality you wouldn't
really have a reason to but still you
know at the end of the day you end up
having the soldier basically throw a
spear of sorts which impales carol
danvers mom carol danvers in turn
responds by literally just like
annihilating the soldier you know just
like wiping her out uses you know
tapping into her white dwarf powers and
then of course the mother of Carol
Danvers dies but again like everything
that goes on here is it's kind of
intriguing because the way the story's
written is kind of unnecessary
I love Margaret stoles writing and this
was not really a slide against her not
at all so marker soul if you happen to
see this it's not a slide against you
not by any standard of measurement I
love your writing style what I find
interesting about this is that this
could have just been done in like a
handbook this could've been a backup
feature and that would have been the end
of that it could've been done quick fast
and in a hurry it's cool to see the
story and undoubtedly was ordered by
Marvel for the sake of just selling
comics but still it is intriguing to see
how it all goes down but let me know you
guys thing down in the down in the
comment section but would that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here too
comments explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later purse
[Music]